Speaker 1: Let's hear from some more people via
discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's go to Kansas where? KC From
Kansas. KC Because you're in Kansas,
obviously you're really happy that the Kansas
City, Kansas chief won the Super Bowl, right?
Speaker 2: I don't watch any sports, Paul.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. It was a joke because Trump
once seemed to think that the Kansas City Chiefs
were from Kansas rather than Missouri, but it went
over like a lead balloon, my friend. I'm sorry.
Speaker 2: Yeah, he just is ignoring
the simple fair.
Speaker 1: But no,
but hold on, KC, You know that Kansas City,
Missouri is in a different state. Yeah,
you do. Okay, good. All right.
Speaker 2: Okay. But I just had a
question because somebody was talking you were
talking about like the how defensive and slow
the Democrats are sometimes.
Speaker 1: Yes, sir.
Speaker 2: Do you think that the Democrats
should just like, stop focus testing and
fixating on polls entirely? Like, I.
Speaker 1: Don't know that Democrats
are. What do you and what evidence do you
have that Democrats are focusing on polls.
Speaker 2: Like in the first six months of Biden's
presidency, he was not really doing much. Okay.
Speaker 1: Well, he did the COVID stimulus right.
Speaker 2: Focused vaccine.
Speaker 1: Rollout.
Speaker 2: They came up
with the phrase mega, mega.
Speaker 1: Maga. Maga.
Speaker 2: Yeah. They didn't accomplish anything.
Like he came out and he said, Oh, these are like
maga maga Republicans. It turned out that that
was from Democratic advisors doing like focused
testing with a bunch of, you know, groups being
like, okay, yeah, this sounds the worst Maga maga.
Speaker 1: You know what's crazy is this
is the first I've ever heard that term.
Speaker 2: I think it was mega, Mega.
But it might have been something.
Speaker 1: No, you're right. I just
Googled it. It's absolutely true that
that was a thing. But you mentioning
it is the first I've ever heard of it.
Speaker 2: But yeah, back when this was
happening, I was just like it felt like the
Democrats weren't really, like doing, like an
aggressive strategy for a while. And the first
thing that Biden comes up with is Maga MAGA after
sitting on a focus group for six months. I think
that sort of stuff is a problem at all.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think it's I
think it's just kind of a waste, you know? And
here's the thing. It's not wrong to think that
the right nicknames for things can be effective
because let's be honest, Trump got the term
Crooked Hillary to stick to Hillary Clinton. Trump
got sleepy. Joe Biden to stick to Joe Biden among.
Speaker 2: So like, he didn't take
six months to come up with that.
Speaker 1: Well, we don't know. We I
guess I'm not sure how long it took him,
but he came up with it as the point. So I
think it's right to think that messaging
and nicknames and those types of things can can
be important. I just don't necessarily know that
focus group testing them is the right way to go.
Speaker 2: Okay. Now, do you think that they
should get new strategy advisors like entirely?
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know. I mean,
maybe. Yeah. It's very easy for me to
say that. I think the approach needs to
change. It's possible that the current
advisors and strategists would be fine
if they could agree on what is the different
approach going to be? I don't know that they
want to do that, though.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I guess now.
But yeah, it's all ahead.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, Casey,
thank you for the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: Thank you. There is Casey
from Kansas, not Missouri, from Kansas.